is this a wd Wireless passport Pro in a
sponsored video to go with it yes it is
[Music]
what's up WD wants to sponsor another
video my passport wireless pro so it's
harder if you can dump footage directly
into a borrow it from your phone yes so
we could like bring this on site with us
and just dump and then we'll never lose
footage again you never intend to like
since we're shooting so much constantly
losing footage this year we've been
pretty bad at it we get done shooting
since we have to get up and shoot
something else right away we never have
time is dumb so we could just dump the
footage where you have to you to mind I
heard it's great because I worry about
footage oh ah the question is quite as
clear if Jake's cool with letting us
have this with us all the time Jake what
steps on how we've lost footage a couple
times in the last year
yep I'm familiar with why yeah we're
thinking we could bring it on the set
with us from now on and I kind of change
up our workflow so instead of collecting
all the cards when we get back from the
studio each other on set right away yeah
that allows you to do that yeah have you
tested it no but we were thinking like
from now on we take this on set with us
and before we even leave we just dump
all the cards or in the car on the way
back so that way we could just move on
and shoot something else where we
wouldn't get to the studio yeah I'm
gonna have to worry about like gathering
all the cards dumping them all or just
go home early yeah I mean that's cool in
theory I don't know if it's gonna work
though we should actually do a test yeah
I mean you can go shoot a bunch of stuff
with a bunch of cameras and see how fast
the condenses I have something to show
you guys first I started wearing this
shirt because I want to be able to hide
when people need me
so I can blend into the colors at the
wall or jig right you come where did you
go guys
get all my cameras got all my SD card
TFS card mag brought the drive right
I don't know charcoal
Oh Michael no all right we forgot the
passport you really got any more get
something and do it
[Music]
we would cinema camera wave a DSLR we
are going to shoot with everything we
can
we're shooting Jake who's no longer
there Oh freaking farming footage over
here
[Music]
by
yes what kind of bird do you think those
from and I didn't get spurred render
your camera
we've ambiguous you got to get the bad
luck you got to take your mind you got
to get a map get enough soul get the bag
of gold versus mad about that you gotta
be a very much better better better
somebody gonna get a buddy help in some
big way better take that man better get
a bunch of soul that brand ambiguous
turns your phone while you're at it
yep oh you can use this for the fun part
yep it is 507 right now go from wrap on
the shoot - how long do packing up and
leaving generally takes that's not the
window we'd have to dump hard if this
can dump the footage that we took in
under a half hour finished wrap up a
sheared get all the gear into the cars
and then get out of there
then it will be really really useful for
us so if this can do it and under that
time at the perfect time and place to
get all the footage in one spot we can
easily transfer it when we get back to
this oh it's dumping it's dumping dude
look at that video video sides just went
up with 25 gigs yeah now it's linking it
to those 20 gigs on this card we're at
already 11 gigs dumped that's fast and
we are three minutes in checking it got
auto format so here's here's the footage
instead of like telling it to import I'm
going to do automatic import it should
mean that moment I put it in to start
dumping it we've only been loading out
for 8 minutes I mean look at the shots
that we just got and DSLR while that's
dumb
oh oh wait we can actually do this this
kind
but colonel but everybody's of the bask
in my sound and let the Maleficarum on
ambiguous so we just did all that in 19
minutes congratulations and all the
footage is there all the footage is
right here all the digital art stuff and
all the cinema camera stuff well I'm
kind of impressed and we can go back to
the studio and not have to worry about
dumping stuff all we have to do is it's
right here don't drop the are drive
because I formatted all the cards once
we get back to the studio all I need to
do is plug the wireless Pro into the my
cloud server push one button and
automatically transfers all the files on
the passport to the server from there
you can access either directly from a
computer or on the network and use all
the files you want to use or if you want
to be a little bit more organized you
can use the app to move things around
where they need to be rather than
collecting a bunch of cards when we get
back to the office dumping them
individually we've saved time and only
had to push one button when we got back
like whoa whoa what's going to happen
you don't know I'm going to double
doubles and then I'll sudden whoa then
all of a sudden you're off bound whoa
whoa